bonjour grégoire leclercq bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
rien à voir avec l'enseigne du même
monde j'imagine non avoir recours à des
auto entrepreneurs pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire est ce que c'est une
pratique que vous confirmez et pourquoi
ce serait tellement plis fier depuis le
début de la crise alors d'abord
effectivement c'est une pratique nous
confirmons que nous voyons apparaître de
plus en plus fréquemment maintenant dans
l'est dans les missions qui sont donnés
aux auto-entrepreneurs par l'intérieur
de plateformes donc tout ça a trait à ce
qu'on appelle l'économie de plateforme
une pratique une démarche technologique
et une démarche dieu d'amour de deux
mille ans de mise en lien entre des auto
entrepreneurs et la grande distribution
qui n'existait pas il ya encore quatre
ou cinq ans oui ça s'est accéléré
pendant la crise pour deux raisons la
première c'est que la grande
distribution a eu et c'est d'ailleurs
pas la seule il ya tout un tas d'autres
secteurs qui ont le même le même souci
ils ont eu des besoins très massif de
recrutement de main d'oeuvre pour
réaliser des missions qui n'étaient pas
habituelles chez eux par exemple
effectivement le toutes les contraintes
liées aux règles sanitaires
la mise en place d'un drive devenir
beaucoup plus généralisée que ça ne
l'était avant
on voit bien qu'il ya une demande assez
forte une recrudescence n'a mans 2-2
besoin de la part des enseignes de
grande distribution puis la deuxième
c'est que dans le même temps et une
révolution générale du monde du travail
qui se produit qui est en train de se
mettre en place c'est pas neuf mais ça
ne fait que s'accélérer et notamment
celle et chez les jeunes le fait
finalement de recourir à
l'auto-entreprise la micro-entreprise
une activité indépendante plutôt qu'une
activité par intérim à la quitter en cdd
n'est plus choquant il ya cinq six ans
on vous aurait proposé d'être en cdd ou
d'être indépendant auto entrepreneur
vous n'auriez pas hésité vous seriez
partie sur un cdd ou sur de la terrible
parce que ça nous paraissait plus
protecteur parce que vous vous avez
finalement une forme de reflex le
salariat reste le plus protecteur reste
le plus adapté à ce que je veux faire de
ma carrière
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui a beaucoup d'auto
entrepreneur beaucoup de jeunes
étudiants beaucoup de jeunes
professionnels finalement remettre tout
ça en cause se disent que après tout
être auto entrepreneur c'est pas si mal
qu'il ya des protections sociales qui
sont certes moindre mais des
sont plus élevées c'est toujours la
balance que l'on voit entre les deux
finalement on peut être mieux rémunérés
comme auto entrepreneur mais on n'a pas
le chômage on peut être mieux rémunérés
mais on n'a pas forcément toute la
protection sociale qui va avec
et donc quand on est jeune qu'on est
étudiant et qu'on a encore finalement
c'est en lien avec votre sujet président
sur les retraites
quarante ans de travail à réaliser on se
dit finalement c'est pas trois ou six
mois
d'autant entreprise qui va changer grand
chose à une un dessin est un parcours de
carrière
alors en quoi est-ce que ça frôle un peu
avec lui légalité puisque c'est
finalement ces postes ont été faits sur
des postes identiques de salariés c'est
exactement le même travail qu'ils
effectuent ces auto-entrepreneurs et
c'est là que ça pose un petit problème
alors ça frôle avec l'égalité même si
encore une fois il faut faire très
attention quand on quand on décrypte un
peu le monde des plates formes parce que
chaque plateforme est différente chaque
mission est différente
effectivement on n'est pas
systématiquement dans une démission qui
sont exactement identiques à celles
qu'on confie à des à des salariés en cdd
un cdi ou un intérim mais il faut
reconnaître que le sujet juridique mais
loin d'être arrêté il faut d'ailleurs
redire les grands principes que la cour
de cassation ne cesse d'évoquer en
permanence la jurisprudence est
constante sur le sujet
la subordination sous les ordres d'un
responsable dans un travail à organiser
notamment en équipe et quand même un
énorme faisceau de requalification en
contrat de travail donc finalement même
si vous ne travaillez que quelques
heures dans une logique de
requalification potentiel finalement de
subordination très forte avec un chef
alors vous êtes susceptible de vous
retrouver plutôt salariés car dépendant
mais parce que la subordination ce n'est
pas seulement ce n'est pas le cas des
auto entrepreneurs c'est là où est le
problème
il devrait pas être subordination parce
que s'ils sont subordination à sont là
ils perdent le statut et finalement la
caractéristique même de ce que c'est
qu'un indépendant qui décide finalement
comment il va réaliser sa tâche presque
quand et où il va réaliser sa tâche
n'est pas le cas pour tous les
indépendants puisque évidemment quand
vous êtes maçons plombiers ou vous
décidez pas de réaliser votre activité
chez vous alors que vous devez la risée
sur le chantier en tout cas vous avez
une forme de liberté dans le yacht de
l'organisation de votre travail not only
forte
des raisons de votre travail qui n'est
pas toujours compatibles avec un travail
dans un service organisé de grande
distribution
pour autant je mets un peu en le propos
en balance il n'ya pas encore
aujourd'hui je risque lens arrêtée sur
le sujet le cas pas de
d'auto-entrepreneur qui sont allés
jusqu'à une demande de requalification
alors qu'il travaille en grande
distribution pour des missions courtes
qui déterrait qualifiant salariés pour
l'instant ça n'existe pas et 2
effectivement il faudrait regarder en
détail quelles sont les missions que
l'on qu'on leur demande de réaliser
certaines sont beaucoup plus ponctuelle
est beaucoup plus autonome par exemple
comme le fait de relever des des prix
dans les rayons de réaliser des enquêtes
de satisfaction prêt dès que des
consommateurs ou même de se rendre sur
le parking pour distribuer des flyers
qui est très différente du fait de
mettre en rayon ou de réapprovisionner
un drive ya pas de contrat de signé
entre la personne qui travaille et et la
grande surface
est ce que ça peut ouvrir la voie aussi
à des abus ou pas alors ça c'est la
grande salle à grandes missions que nous
en tant que fédération des
auto-entrepreneurs nous nous demandons
de respecter aux plateformes
en fait il faut être très très clair les
plateformes aujourd'hui joue un rôle
d'intermédiaire mais vont au delà
finalement elles sont un peu le
garde-fou de ces abus elles sont là pour
lever les alertes sont là pour garantir
justement une indépendance à ces auto
entrepreneurs ils sont là pour justement
dire quand on a franchi la ligne rouge
il ne faut pas que les plateformes se
cachent derrière leur petit doigt en se
disant qu' il n'y aura jamais de
problème de requalification où il n'y
aura jamais de problème d'abus il y en
aura il y en aura comme il y en a eues
avec les humeurs des livres ou et autres
et autres vtc ou livreur à vélo et donc
il faut absolument que ces plateformes
joue un rôle de vigie joue un rôle
honnête de tirer le signal d'alarmé
quand il y à des abus donc évidemment
c'est compliqué pour elle parce que
elles sont entre deux feux finalement
elles sont entre l'auto entrepreneur qui
aime bien sa vie et entre la plaie la
grande surface qui elle a besoin de main
d'oeuvre et qui devait par ailleurs les
paye je rappelle que le modèle c'est la
plateforme prend 20% sur toutes les
missions que la grande surface varie va
lui confier donc c'est sûr que c'est un
sujet que l'on surveille de près et que
l'on ne cessera d'ailleurs de de garder
dans notre d'entre d'entre eux servent à
thouars pendant les
qui viennent c'est une pratique coin on
l'a dit que c'est un généralisée pendant
la crise sanitaire les grandes surfaces
le disent d'ailleurs il y avait besoin
de main d'oeuvre à cause de
l'absentéisme aussi c'est une pratique
qui s'est fait pendant la crise mais
est-ce qu'elle va perdurer justement
c'est aussi la crainte qu'on peut avoir
ouais au détriment des gros bras environ
oui en fait c'est la grande question à
laquelle il ya c'est difficile de
répondre mais je pense quand même que on
a ouvert une porte finalement on a alors
certains vont dire on a ouvert une
brèche dans ce que j'appelle moi la
réforme des mondes de travailler dans
finalement la réforme de la delà du
rapport au travail qu'on les salariés ou
les français finalement avec l'heureux
leur entreprise ou leur demeure dans on
l'a déjà vu avec le monde des vtc le
monde est livreur à vélo on le voit avec
le monde de la grande distribution
je pense qu'on le voit aussi beaucoup
avec les prestations intellectuelles
on le voit et tout le monde des
traducteurs on va être le monde et des
de tous les to le tourisme évidemment
tout ce qui touche à la visite ou lits
touristiques et puis bien sûr on le voit
maintenant avec voilà cette grande
distribution le recours aux travailleurs
indépendants est assez facile au travers
des pendants ait assez lucratif pour le
train arrière de prendre lui-même et
donc il est fort à parier que l'on
revienne à quelque chose d'un peu plus
équilibré que ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui je
pense pas que toutes les grandes
surfaces ou continuer à avoir un recours
aussi massif qu'elles ne l'ont eue
pendant la crise aux travailleurs
indépendants et je pense qu'il va y
avoir une sorte d'équilibré un peu un
peu à un peu plus stable qui va se
mettre en place
et comme je le disais aussi beaucoup
d'auto entrepreneur finalement préfère
l'indépendance au salariat pour des
raisons assez évident de rémunération
supérieure
et puis aussi pour des raisons de 2,2 de
projection dans l'avenir qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas leur quotidien savoir
combien aux côtés de sa retraite quand
on a 22 ans ou 25 ans finalement c'est
pas vraiment un sujet d'ailleurs quand
nous étions nous mêmes étudiants on
avait recours à de l'intérim ou à des
jobs d'été qui étaient pas d'air
beaucoup mieux protégés que ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui les auto
entrepreneurs
je pense que les choses ont quand même
perdurer peut-être dans une proportion
un peu moindre que ce qu'on a connu là
mais à mon avis elles vont perdurer
après la crise donc vous dites que ça
touche plutôt un public
mais plutôt une bonne chose quand on
voit le chômage qui les touchent
particulièrement c'est aussi le la
confrontation avec le réel c'est vous
les échos quand vous êtes un jeune
d'étudiants ou jeunes diplômés
on ne vous opposerez à d'autres sur le
marché que des petits jobs d'intérim ou
des petits jobs d'auto-entrepreneur
finalement vous n'avez pas non plus la
largeur du choix vous faites ce que vous
pouvez avec ce que vous propose
effectivement quand vous propose de 10
euros bruts c'est-à-dire 8 euros net ou
13 euros bruts c'est-à-dire 11 euros
nets
quand vous êtes auto-entrepreneur ben
finalement vous prenez les 11 euros et
donc quand vous êtes jeune et vous fait
vos premiers danse professionnelle dans
une grande surface ou encore une fois
dans du street marketing dans des
sondages dans la campagne campagne de
publicité etc
vous le prenez comme une première
expérience je ne crois pas je ne tire
pas le signal d'alarmé jusqu'à dire que
on est en train de détruire l'ensemble
du salariat avec ce type de pratiques
ça reste quand même un épiphénomène dans
un secteur effectivement jeunes avec des
métiers qui sont de toute façon pas
prolifique en cdi ou en cdd
merci beaucoup grégoire leclercq pour
toutes ses explications ce matin en
direct dans la matinale